hello everyone I hope you're having an
excellent Sunday and I really hope this
game will further improve it it's a game
from round five of the 2018 Batumi Chess
Olympiad between a vastly von Schuch
representing Ukraine and David Anton we
are representing Spain and we're going
to talk about the results of the matchup
and the entire standings after round 5
after we check out this game but before
that we do have a couple of nice photos
before the game as you as you all know
Saturday was the rest day at the Olympia
so everyone was you know they're able to
do something else
non chess related so here we have a very
nice photo by David Lada it's a photo
from his visit to the dolphinarium
if if that is in fact a word a very nice
photo of two dolphins jumping but it's
even as if they were flying so I thought
you know you'd enjoy a nice photo like
this I mean who doesn't enjoy a nice
dolphin photo and then also a photo by
david Lada which really impressed me was
this photo of Levon Aronian with with a
t-shirt of a black cat same cat now I'm
sure there's some reason to this photo
but I found it very interesting because
I know perhaps even you know our union
has a dog he and his wife have a dog but
today is their anniversary the dog's
name is panchak and you know he's a
pretty famous dog and he's also a very
good boy so Ireland having a cat shirt I
really found this interesting so I
thought you'd enjoy it as well so we're
not gonna have too much photos before
this game let's let's just check it out
as it is a very nice game if one chuck
has the white pieces and he opens with
the d4 I don't know if you remember I
think it was in 2016 during the
Gibraltar chess festival
David David Anton reached the finals
well he he won but he also won with
Hikaru Nakamura and then they had to go
into tiebreaks where Nakamura was able
to defeat him but it was a very
impressive result he goes Knight to f6
we have c4 e6 Knight to f3 and
David proceeds to the Queens gambit
declined of course III by van choke
we have b6c captors on d5 pawn captors
on d5 and now Bishop to d3 Bishop to d6
and now comes castles we have castles
and now comes the b3 it's a it's a very
not not yet nothing every day try with
the black pieces to immediately give
this light-square bishop some activity
as blacks mostly most of the times in
the Queens gambit declined the blacks
biggest problem will be how to develop
this light square Bishop so this early
b6 does seem to take care of it but as
you'll see in the game black ball some
problems in his attempts to execute c5
so as we've said eventually pushes a b3
prepares a rush up to a3 as e3 was
already played he does have to do
something about his dark square bishop
so his claim is Bishop to e3 to exchange
it for
davits strong dark square Bishop rook to
e8 with a brush up to a3 as planned
butter up to g4 Bishop captures on d6
Queen captures on d6 and not nice to see
three and here are although a c5 does
seem like the way to go Anton decides he
doesn't want to leave his d5 point so
rather he plays c6 he strengthens his d5
pawn but now for a very long time the c6
pawn will be a weak backwards pawn and
it will not be all that easy to get rid
of it if one should place rook the c1 he
starts his a onslaught on the semi-open
c-file Knight B to d7 and now Bishop to
e2 Avant your plans to exchange the
light square bishop as well
rook a to C 8 and now Queen to c2
we have nice to e4 and now comes Knight
to d2 again
black does wanna buy a black would very
much enjoy playing c5 but if you try c5
immediately you get Queen to d3 and
again there's no no good way to exploit
this for example C capture Sun before
Queen captures and again you will be
left with this isolated d5
upon which I'm sure is playable I feel
like isolated pawns if not you're not
going to go for this after Queen to c2
we have Knight to e4 and now Avenger
plays Knight to d2 his idea is to
exchange everything Knight captures
Queen captures and Bishop captures we
have Queen captures and now comes the
knight to f6
perhaps this night is coming to e4 at
some point but again it wasn't all that
easy to execute c5 if c5 here then
simply D captures be captures on c5 and
now rook F to d1 piling up on the d5
pawn and after d4 that for example Queen
to d2 and now this this pawn will be
lost
so after Queen to e2 Knight to f6
bringing a knife to a nice square like
we said nicely for could be an idea at
some point how about also strengthening
the d5 point if if c5 is ever to be
executed we have looked the c2 by vine
choke eventual has plans of e eater
doubling rooks on the C file we'll see
but perhaps this depending on what black
plays perhaps even bring the rook to a
one and then trying to break through on
the Queen side here still c5 is not
played rook to c7 still waiting with
this execution of c5 we have rook F 2 c1
and now look III 7 I I thought rook c8
was was the idea here but Anton's idea
is rook to e7 and then he will bring the
knight - eh to improve his defense of
the rock and c7 we have Queen to have
three now again preventing c5 if you try
c5 now doesn't doesn't really make any
sense nice to the b5 would fork would
fork the Queen and the rook so we have
knife to e8 as planned we have Knight to
e2 and the now comes rook to c8 trying
again with this c5 again makes makes no
sense as event she would simply bring
the knight back with a double attack
against the d5 pawn and if you try to
try to defend it then again you get
night to the b5 and the Queen and rook
get forked so after 90 to look to see it
and now comes
Queen to f4 even she wants to trade
Queens as he says that the only semi
open file on the board is the C file and
the von Schuch it's pretty much
controlling it at some point he will put
b4 and black will never be able to
execute c5 we have Queen to g6 Anton
decides he will not straight wins and
now we have h3 a very nice move
Avantika is preparing a queen trade and
here we have h6 perhaps Anton should
should not have allowed this Queen trade
but I guess he thought it was manageable
I want to place Queen to g4 and now the
Queen trade cannot be avoided as of
course this is the offer but also the
rook and c8 is under attack so you do
have to trade Queens we have Queen
captures pawn captures and now comes
rook eat the c7 and now comes Knight to
f4 the threat of course is if this night
would ever move then ideas like Knight
captures on d5 would be possible and
it's not all that all that easy for
black to find the plan of course you
cannot push c5 anymore because now the
d5 pawn is weak and it doesn't really
make sense to push away tonight if you
put away the knife Knight comes to d3
against e5 square is very well covered
and then the knight can also come to e5
on the other hand after this Knight to
f4 if you try something like Knight to
f6 now to give this pawn further
protection then before again your black
is never pushing c5 in this game so
after Knight to f4 we have King to f8
improving the position of the king and
the now comes Knight to d3 this is a
very nice move by ban choke you have to
find I realizable plan here there is no
like like a move but but you rather you
have to find a nice plan and the one she
explained starts of course with a move
that is with the knight back his idea is
he has he has more control of the of the
semi-open c-file and the real weakness
in blacks camp is the backwards c6 pawn
so his idea is a knife to d3 to be four
to A six four if the knight gets to a
since then he will be able to dislodge
one of the defenders of the c6 pawn and
of course rook a person c6 is the idea
so 9th to d3 that's only one of the
plans if black doesn't defend well
against it if he does then also the
knight is very nice on d3 so King to e7
Antone's idea is that he he will not
stop him and to explain off moving the
rock but he will bring the King here to
include another defender of the c6 pawn
nice to be four by one choke and here we
have King to d6 again you cannot push c5
still you lose this with check and you
lose the game
so King to d6 and now we want to display
night to a6 right now you have to move
the rook rook to b7 is played and now
comes before and now completely removing
any hopes of black playing c5 we have b5
at some point black if if the if this
night ever moves perhaps rook to e8
followed by a five will be possible so
here he one should replace night the c5
he kicks the rook back now be the c4
would be an excellent square for
Franklin's night if he could ever get it
there for example if the King moves he
could go King here and then a knight
here and then bring the knight over to
c4 but the King has to keep an eye on
this pawn another idea would be
something like night see seven to eight
then come to b6 and only then come to c4
but in watch who doesn't allow such
ideas first he plays nice to see five he
attacks the rook rook has to move and
now comes Knight back to d3 a von Schuch
is hoping to provoke some weaknesses as
this night can come to e5 so f6
displayed here but perhaps even better
than f6 which has been rocked to a6
either forcing white to deal with the
idea of this rook coming to a3 thus
really increasing its activity or at
least this rook will not be able to move
so much as it has to keep an eye on this
a to pawn but f6 is played rather than
this taking away d5 square from from
whites night and now we want to place
rook to c3 however a nice move now rook
to a6 will be made
to which the simple a 3 as the rook will
be protecting it from me from c3 so King
to d7 the knight is now coming to d6
Knights the c5 check King has to move
and now comes rogue to a one I want you
is perhaps planning to push a four we
have looked to a eight and now first
comes Knight to b3 a four is a four is
an idea but first you want to prevent a
black from pushing a 5/9 to d6 finally
this Knight is able to come into play
and now comes a 4s planned
Knight to c4 and now comes a rook to c2
we have King to f7 and the black king is
now coming over to the Kings side and
then out comes rook c2e2 so from the C
file you want to allow the black to
close the C file but now the DA file
which will definitely open at some point
King to g6 now comes a capture son b5
rope captors on b5 and the rook captures
on a7 rope captures rook captures and
rook captures on b4 and the night to the
c5 the material on the board is now
completely equal and even if on Chuck
has a WG points but the problem is white
rook is much more active and the white
knight is much more active another thing
Black has to point out once that one
white has only one point island so
that's definitely an advantage for white
and another thing is white really
doesn't have all that many weak bones on
the other hand the c6 pawn is still a
very weak pawn the rook can simply
attack it and on the other hand the g7
point is a very weak pawn the rook and
the knight can combine an attack against
it so it will be very difficult for
although the material on the board is
equal at the moment it will be very
difficult for and for David to keep all
the pawns intact Knight to d6 first and
okay we have rocked the seas rock to c7
attacking the c6 pawn and now rope to b6
now blacks pieces are very passive here
this rook is stuck defending the c6 pawn
that's no way for your rook to to play
the endgame and the knight isn't really
doing all that much we have night to e6
here Evon shook is threatening to
capture and g7 and now Knight to e8
the only way to guard this pawn
we have looked to e7 attacking the
knight and the rook to b8 and here f4 by
Rancho so now with this F remove even
shook sort of puts dab it into into a
tube swung as the rook can't move the
rook has to keep an eye on the night if
the knight moves then you lose the g7
point the king has nowhere to go really
okay you can play King to h7 but f5
takes away even more squares from the
black King
so after this f4 move you kind of have
to push a pawn and you don't really have
a good point to push so that it tries f5
here simply g5h garrison g5 will have
pawn captures on g5 and again you didn't
really gain anything you still have to
play something again if you play
something like King to h7 quite simply
improves King to f2 King to a trait I
always say King to f3 and then now after
g6 ok your pawns are now very solid but
now white can simply bring his King over
over to the center of the board and
black doesn't really have any plans
white can always exchange rooks and then
bring his King into the game and start
grabbing pawns
so FFF captors and g5 Knight to d6 was
played Anton tries giving up one point
for some activity and of course Avant
you grabs it rook captures on g7 we have
king to h5 and now comes a rock to h7
with check King to g6 and now comes a
king to g4 hands now comes g6 as past
points must be pushed we have F 4 and
now g7 event
completely ignores the pawn there's
really no point in capturing it because
here night to f8 wins the game you
simply block off the rogues defense of
the g8 Square and even if black pushes
e2 which does seem very dangerous g8
Queen comes with to check and at once
you remove the King of course now the
black king is in the mating net for
example Queen e6 checking a 425 check
King G for Rho G 7 check Tim to h4 and
now Queen to H 2 this will be checkmate
so after this g7 move
we have Knight to f5 keeping an eye on
the pawn and also keeping around on the
e3 pawn but it doesn't really matter
here we have e cap
on f4 now knife to f8 wouldn't wouldn't
be all that impressive because Knight to
e7 would guard the g8 square from
queening another nice idea after this
knife comes to defy f5 so after Knight
to a5 we have a captures on f4 by von
Schuch simply eliminating blacks passed
pawn we have rook to e8 and now comes
King to f2 if I drew simply ignores the
rook as rook captures Knight is not
possible you would simply Queen the pawn
rook to e8 antone has to wait and here
we have a very nice move rook to h3
simply bringing the rook back we have
looked way to check King to g1 and now
rook goes back to 8th event you Heights
is king on h2 and now we have rook to e8
and here it's this is a very nice
position as there is a there is really a
beautiful beautiful combination here
which both divine choke and David missed
it's a very nice idea and this feature
the same theme that was already present
in the game so it's I mean it's a
winning position for white so of course
you don't need to find any cool
combinations when there is a winning
position but you have all the time in
the world
presumably so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the idea a
crushing move that both of them missed
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are truly a great
endgame player and you know a finder of
hidden combinations and for those who
just want to enjoy it show rook the c3
was played in the game and it's very
possible to play it every a lot of moves
are winning here but rook the g3 check
wins the game on spot now well let's see
what happens if you capture the rook if
you capture the rook then it's pretty
self-explanatory Knights to a fate this
is the theme that was already present in
the game you simply take away the g8
squared the defense of the g8 square
from the rook and now pawn to g8 wins
the game whatever black plays or you
captured the night and then pawn pawn
captures rook with with a queen
whatever black plays you simply bring a
queen and it's all over but the very
enjoyable the most enjoyable part is
what happens
if you don't capture the rook if you for
example play King to h4 well then then
you get nice to f8 you take away the g8
we're from the rook and now after Knight
captures on g7 it seems like everything
is fine for black but now you get rook
to g5 and this is the monster move
there is no defense here Knight to g6 is
the threat of checkmate if you capture
the night then you get g3 again this is
checkmate and if you don't capture the
night if you prevent g3 by painting the
pawn then you get nice to g6 checkmate
so this rook to g5 moved truly truly a
masterpiece you know if it was the only
winning winning line I'm sure even she
would have found it but as so many moves
win here it doesn't really matter if one
should play truck to c3 still black has
no moves you might you can play whatever
he wants here Rock to g8 now comes rogue
back to a3 again you can't capture the
pawn here if you capture again you get
rook to g3 check King moves and Knight
captures you lose a piece so after rook
to e8 we have rope to a6 there's no
point in defending the pawn you you will
simply capture the rook has to keep an
eye on the g8 square so no point in
capturing this after rook to a 6 we have
Knight to g7 die with Christ
giving up a piece in order to perhaps
you know get rid of all the pawns and
perhaps draw this game ah but it's
easier said than done
Oh Kevin Knight captures and g7 rook to
e7 and now rook to a3 of course you
cannot trap the night because now if you
capture look to g3 picks up the rook so
came to a4 and now comes rock to f3
check a King moves and now Knight to a5
the knight escapes you know any possible
entrapment rook to e4 attacking the pawn
now simply night to e3 check King moves
and after nights to see - it was almost
67 that David Antonin we had resigned
the game he resigned there's really
nothing to do any attempts to take
change your pawns and go for something
for example
c5 pawn captures rook the c4 with an
attack on the knight and the pawn Knight
moves rook captures pawn but now Knight
a5 check King moves and down rook
captures here your upper piece and up a
passed pawn a completely winning game
game so Davi knows this and after
Knights the c2 again very fitting for
adventure to finish the game with with a
move that is a move with the knight back
a very very important victory for
Ukraine against Spain as here we have
these are all the results across the
boards eventual class Lee versus David
Anton we are oh there is our victory for
revenge hook Pahlavi leonov lost on
board - so a bunch of ICH turi was all
the more important a critical one on
board three and then a roost on Palomar
I drew on board for which makes it two
and a half to one and a half for Ukraine
in Ukraine's favor and we've already
seen this yesterday these are the
results after round five round six is
already being played at the moment I'm
recording this so perhaps some of the
games have already finished but yeah
there we have it as a rabbit Jon Czech
Republic Poland and Ukraine with a
perfect score so far it's gonna be very
intense so there we have it
I was gonna show this game yesterday but
there was a craft beer festival in my
hometown so of course I had to visit
that but yeah I do hope you enjoyed this
game and that you're enjoying the
courage of the Olympiad so far I will
try to cover as many interesting games
as possible and don't worry about the
future series we're gonna return to that
as soon as possible but we do have to
cover some of the games from deal impede
I do want to thank Anthony Woodside
Davidge tine avid matters dog Peter
Wentworth and gurgi call it for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video er thank y'all for watching and I
will see soon hopefully with another
interesting video and as usual to check
all the links to the official Olympiad
social pages thank you all and I'll see
you soon